bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france d'arbres emmanuel
macron positif on imagine bien
évidemment qu'il a respecté tous les
restes barrières aux commandes et même
rendu obligatoire par l'exécutif oui on
peut espérer qu'il est plus respecté
tous les gestes barrières vont tout
d'abord en tant que médecin et politique
mais en tant que médecin lui souhaiter
un prompt rétablissement en lui c'est en
aucune complication ni immédiatement ni
de l'ordre du kovy blond qui semble être
quand même une pathologie très
contraignante en tant que politique ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que quand on
voit la longue une numération des
rendez-vous qu'il a eue depuis huit à
dix jours le nombre de conseils de
réunion c'est une chose avec la
distanciation
mais peut-être pas le point que l'on ce
qu'on ne peut plus serré la main pour
lui serrer mais le point que l'on touche
qui est quand même un contact cutané
je note qu'il a eu quand même pas mal de
déjeuner et de ne repart du multiple
donc il n'y a pas eu de principe de
précaution voilà depuis le 1er janvier
aucun des dirigeants de la planète n'a
mis en place véritablement des principes
de précaution qui au delà des gestes
barrières qu'on nous a appris au fur et
à mesure consiste aussi à avoir de
l'intelligence du moment et que des
politiques et surtout pratiquement la
totalité du gouvernement soit exposée
comme ça me semble tout à fait
ahurissant
il faut savoir être pragmatique et être
comment dirais-je vraiment responsable
ne pas multiplier autant de rendez-vous
les visio conférences sont très
importantes elles devraient être
multipliées bien plus que cela même s'il
y a des rendez vous importants
alors ça vous redire que la
contamination du président c'est un peu
un coup plus entre par rapport à la
confiance entre le gouvernement et les
français c'est aussi là la traduction du
fait que malgré des sommes folles qui
ont été mises sur la table pour la
recherche
à ce jour on n'a toujours pas
véritablement idée des modes de
contamination
on est à peu près sûr maintenant et on
comprend tout ce qui est par là
respiration les postillons et même des
particules fines par la peau on se dit
ne touchait pas le visage ne vous serrez
pas les mains et ne vous embrasser pas
mais il semblerait que la peau soit une
voie beaucoup plus importante pour ne
croit puisque le virus reste réellement
sur la peau 8 à 9 heures de la même
façon on n'a aucune étude sur le circuit
de la vaisselle lors des repas on le
sait en cuisine mais on ne le sait pas
en salle on n'a pas véritablement fait
des expertises et puis il ya peut-être
d'autres voies de contamination qui font
que plus on fréquente du monde puis on
fréquente ne serait-ce même que les
personnes qui entourent les gens du
gouvernement
plus il y a des chances d'être
contaminés il est urgent pour né des
réponses sur les modes de contamination
commence en avoir quelques pistes mais
pas assez et est ce que vous comprenez
le peu de confiance accordée au vaccin
par les français alors je le comprends
d'autant plus que j'ai quand même pu
exercer pendant plus de 45 ans que j'ai
vu la période où il y avait strictement
aucune difficulté à accepter des vaccins
obligatoires qui avait fait la preuve de
leur innocuité
c'était un petit peu plus compliqué
quand on nous a parlé d'hépatite voire
même qu'entre la première épidémie de
h1n1 mais la halle ce qui entoure les
vaccins aujourd'hui pose problème
d'abord parce qu'elle des vaccins
nouveaux cas l arn messager que les
contrats qui ont été négociées à
l'europe en ont au nom des états sur les
contrats qui à ce jour sont totalement
opaques nous n'auront accès peut-être
que lors du septième contrat terminé et
que évidemment il ya une précipitation
dont les français n'étaient pas à
laquelle les français n'étaient pas
habitués pourtant il faudra un moment
donné en passer par là puisque dans la
tente de nouveaux traitements il y en a
qui se prépare il ya des pistes
intéressantes
nous n'avons que ça pour arrêter cette
épidémie sur un virus dont nous ne
savons pas grand chose la hausse il est
urgent de savoir ce qu'est le vaccin
d'où il vient a là une équipe d'experts
qui part en chine cette semaine c'est un
peu tard donc je comprends la défiance
des français
il va falloir qu'il soit quand même très
responsable et ils arriveront
forcément au vaccin jour ou l'autre de
guerre lasse il faut bien dire madame
mais la remercie d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt français merci à vous
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes élu est reine
et député européen mais également
médecin
merci m